[Music]
many americans
are not into the idea of monogamy wow in
january there was a poll of over 1300
u.s adults and i found that one-third
which is 32 percent of the united states
uh um
of the united states uh group of adults
in this poll say their ideal
relationship is non-monogamous where are
they all from san francisco they're from
san francisco whoa how'd you know that
no i'm not
dang
blinding those 43 are particularly
likely to say their ideal relationship
is non-monogamous through an equal
though an equal percentage of this
generation says their ideal relationship
is completely monogamous so
it's like split
but at least a third of people are
saying
that's pretty big yeah because that's
also like a very non-traditional view of
a relationship but that's also only a
poll of 1300 people yes but it's but
it's um which is quite a bit of the
youngins though how old is millennials
we're millennials how often are people
having non-monogamous relationships
these days i feel like there's all kinds
of it's way more open now and there's
even like like more like more than one
person in relationships it's like like
three what are they called polyamorous
poly polygons yeah polygons but i wonder
also out of that percentage how many of
those people are open and honest with
their partners about how they're dating
other people and being well it's just
100 percent like is it
oh it does cool that makes me feel
better thank god that's true is it
cheating or is it yeah i don't think
cheating counts in this it's non-ibus
do you guys think you guys could have um
a polyamorous relationship no i don't do
something if i was mormon yeah but i
think
i feel like it's a dream that people
come up with their in their head but the
logistically once they actually start
doing it it's like probably a pain
here's the thing if the chicks are down
to les out and suck my dick at the same
time
then of course and that's a slam dunk
dude what about back in the day when
like uh when like dudes would have you
know like a king of an area would have
like you know a bunch of wives or
concubines and stuff like that what
about that is i still don't think that's
changed societally
i still think i still think the top 1
of men who are like the top earners in
society
still [ __ ] live like that yeah i do
undisputedly oh is that why all guys
want to be the top one percent somehow
subconsciously yeah probably maybe but
bill gates doesn't do that at least he
does it doesn't look like him didn't he
just do that he had a meet up didn't he
do we did a story about his on the
lolita express huh
it's all paid right so like what i don't
know does it count if it's paid it might
be a cleaner transaction on their end
like instead of like buying the car let
me just rent 12 of them it's almost like
at that level it's almost like you'd be
dumb to not do it paid almost oh because
it's dangerous yeah it's like super
crazy yeah who has the resources to be
able to have a relationship with
multiple people or who would who would
have that just automatic trust for like
a random hookup that you'd be like oh
yeah you're not going to go sell this
information i heard a lot of uh rappers
what they do if they want to hook up
with like groupies or whatever is like
they'll get their id um they'll get like
um like what do you call it the
non-disclosure thingy nda so they know
that they're actually over age
um they have them like save videos like
yeah i wanna [ __ ] so-and-so or whatever
yeah such a weird process right but then
it's because
afterwards people will come after them
with a lawsuit and all these dangerous
things you just hear about the
basketball player who um he's like uh
damn i don't remember i'm not good at
remembering basketball [ __ ] but
he's a basketball player and he was like
i'm gonna get married to this woman i'm
really excited about it and then like
he's like okay hey baby we need to
prenup and he's like she loves me it's
all good she hey baby we need a prenup
she's like yeah i'll get around to it
i'll get around to it and like they're
getting close to the wedding they're
booking all the venues they're doing
[ __ ] putting money down deposits hey
baby we need to prenup oh yeah yeah i
know i'm gonna sign it
it's the day before the wedding hey baby
we need a pre-prenup right
and she's like yeah no i'm still looking
at it but he's like no no this like what
the [ __ ] this needs to happen so the day
of the wedding
he's like okay you're gonna give me the
preamp or not she has her like
um her like friends and her family come
in there and they're like crying and
then being like you don't need this like
what are you doing this to hurt all this
[ __ ] that's so much like [ __ ] weird
and he's like just give me the prenup
what the [ __ ] i want to marry this woman
i love her it's all good i just need the
prenup to make to like make sure that
i'm financially secure because i worked
my [ __ ] ass off before i even knew
her and i need to make sure that my
money's locked in for life
and her shady ass group of friends and
family were like no no no interceding
so then he's like okay cool the
wedding's off
and then he invites all his buddies
and they all just go to the wedding
venue and just have a party yeah yeah
he's in the nba yep wow yeah so he came
he won nba retired but yeah he was like
king dallas
he's like i don't have another contract
coming i'm not going to [ __ ] do this
and enhance somebody might have my money
that happens a lot to athletes yes
because there's like what do you isn't
their name for that like it's like um
all-star weekend especially it's big in
the in the nba for like
a lot of the hookups hookups all the
ladies come around come they don't want
you to use condoms and [ __ ] and they
want to get their check for life like
unfortunately not not like all women are
like that but that's the people who go
but there's cons in both genders it's
like you know it's like the guys want
[ __ ] and they're gonna get conned for
that if it's like being greedy well yeah
but that's dude that's how we work but
yeah i know like if guys are gonna be
greedy for the [ __ ] you're gonna get
scammed one day so do you guys think if
an nba player
came up with his girl
and then they get married do you think
asking for a prenup at that point or
after is a success it's different for
sure it's just changes the conversation
like that i met high school after my
career is totally different than like
yeah we came up together they came up
together like patrick mahomes yeah like
he like kansas city chiefs [ __ ]
signed a crazy contract he was with that
chick since like high school so it's a
different conversation perhaps like he
like he became he became who he was
because of knowing her as well and
there's something like that because i
hear people have that argument i'm
curious what you guys think about that
they're having a robert parish show i
just think whatever the [ __ ] they want
whatever they feel fair in that
relationship we should do it yeah dude
you have to pick for everybody dude pick
it for all of us
damn that's dangerous though well you do
hear some crazy stories about like
there's that one podcast um
the guy with all the tats his name is
adam
oh adam22 22 or whatever or jumpman adam
and he gets all these girls and they
who who talk about how they [ __ ] nba
players all the time oh yeah like selena
powell yeah oh okay yeah she they told a
story about that her friend aliza
they're telling a story about how um
she was like [ __ ] subdued and then 20
was like some like 12 other and like
phoenix suns guys came in the room and
she sucked all their dicks
what
was she like a porn star or something no
she's just a [ __ ] she has a she has a
regular job it's like a accountant or
something but she like told that story
that all of a sudden everyone's like oh
[ __ ] that just put them all out so she
just went one by another she said they
all just came in wow and she just went
around in a circle and just got it got
it done at the same time yeah
like a japanese porno like uh yeah with
those sound effects was any of them
eating morales
that's the best
that sticks up that's the best [ __ ] the
guy who chooses that i'm always like
god damn
i'm also like
the guy that does that thanks because if
i was in that group which grosses me out
but if i was there i'd be like you're
propelling her energy right now she said
she originally was hooking up with
someone from administration or like an
administration administrative guy from
like that team and then who she like
hooks up with usually and then all of a
sudden the team just came in and she
just went all right
and was the guy who was hooking up with
her like
oh no
i can't believe this happened to me i
was gonna marry her
that would be the worst so now it's like
the worst possible concept i'm gonna
hang out here but my life is rude
it's all rude
what have i
it's a crazy ass story i'm not even
gonna blink but i can't believe this is
happening to me
can i go in between you two again
go back to him okay he gets at the back
of the line and he's like ah get out of
here you already had your turn get out
of here no not you no
man you never talked to your girl about
a prenup that never came up once before
getting married nah dude i should i
should she should ask me for a prenup
[Laughter]
she gave me gas money to get here
she's doing with a career in a stable
job i'm on her health insurance really
really good let's go and i heard she has
really good health insurance you got
really good health oh yeah healthy
church is no joke man
it's a real commodity go get your health
insurance kings out there
and then your kids are gonna have it
it's great we're all we're all gonna be
hooked up total 25 and then they're
[ __ ] and they're [ __ ] out of here
that's the threat 25 you're [ __ ] out
here out of here dude i'm hanging over
their head too unless you find chinese
doctors do you know how to work it
around around
yes like the real ones are the holistic
ones no the real ones that's how i've
been getting my contacts all the way up
until i i got my uh
my eye surgery wait what was this [ __ ]
about again
this is about um monogamy
oh
monogamy
but we got to contact lenses and i'm
intrigued so what's your vision
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you